a deadly monsoon season in much of South
Asia in Nepal the aftermath of mass
floods and deadly landslides for the
displaced there's more rain to come
nearby in Bangladesh it's the same story
dangerous flooding and mudslides and for
the revenger refugees from neighboring
mine ma the rain and landslides have
washed away thousands of hillside
shelters leaving several dead we're
having problems during this rainy season
getting food the kids are suffering from
disease toilets and bathrooms are a
problem the kids are not able to go to
school schools are falling into
disrepair these are the problems we face
a huge swath of South Asia used to
monsoons is affected by the floods in
India
Aaron shell Pradesh West Bengal and
Assam with well over a million people
affected as well as livestock and
crucially crops the biggest loss has
been the crops as soon as farmers begin
sewing irrigating the land with electric
pumps and all then the rain began the
rainfall has also been extreme 70 to 72
hours of continuous rain the water level
kept increasing and slowly submerged the
farmlands nearly all of the crops have
been destroyed climate change means more
extreme weather and many a concern about
how that's affecting our food systems
this monsoon and a ruined harvest will
be felt well beyond the end of the rainy
season
it's burgundy w's nimisha jaiswal who is
standing by in Delhi for us so Nimisha
as we've heard there a million people
displaced what are the authorities doing
to help
well Sarah the authorities have deployed
an immense effort because this is an
annual occurrence I mean of course it's
been worse in some parts of Nepal then
it has been in the past but for example
in India the National Disaster Response
Force is one of the biggest disaster
management forces in the world and they
have done an incredible job just earlier
this year there was a massive cyclone
cyclone funny and loss of life was
severe it was was controlled and managed
and even though any the disaster was
managed well so even this time there
have been security forces deployed in
India as flood affected areas in Nepal
as well but there are also massive
challenges they have set up 24/7 health
lines but communication towers have
fallen in Nepal highways have been
blocked so it's also hard for security
forces to deploy these efforts
helicopters on her faces to land so
there's actually a hope that waters will
recede once the rains start easing off
and they would be able to deploy more of
an effort for rescue and recuperation
now we know that flooding it happens
every year in this part of the world how
would you compare this year to previous
years but like I said Sara this year in
Nepal there have been reports the
flooding has been worse in some parts
however all over this particular region
floods are an annual affair and the
challenges in these regions are way
different from built upon areas in India
such as flooding in Mumbai or the city
of Chennai earlier now in these areas
they're more mountainous areas and the
flooding over here causes to a lot of
loss of life because of these areas
lying alongside rivers as well so also
extreme climate change has extreme
weather conditions have become more
common there is an MIT study that
actually predicts that by the end of the
century India would be eighty percent of
India's population would be subject to
extreme weather conditions so this is
something that authorities have to
prepare for even though they can't
prevent floods as such in mountainous
regions they do have to deploy more
forces more efforts to make sure that
people are not as badly effected as they
are every year and look at let's look at
that level of preparedness that you
referenced in Bangladesh specifically
because I mean they have some unique
challenges with hundreds of
thousands of refugees from Myanmar how
are they affected well exactly the
condition in Bangladesh is different and
unique there is the challenge of the
refugee camps close to a million people
are in Cox's Bazar and we saw in the
report that there's also a massive
impact because of the landslides that
have been happening mudslide since April
have taken several lives in those
refugee camps waterborne illnesses are
also a serious challenge but even
overall for Bangladesh the set of
challenges are different from the
regions who are discussing in India and
Nepal because 80% of Bangladesh is
floodplain Bangladesh has been at risk
of being submerged and that risk has
been increasing Europe anja so the
government there even for for the people
outside of the camps even for Bangladesh
trees and other low-lying regions have
had to deploy additional forces and
efforts to make sure that people are not
affected but of course with the Rohingya
camps there is an additional challenge
because here are a million people who
have already been displaced but also
face animal problems because of their
temporary shelter is being affected
because of this massive flooding enemy
should I saw in Delhi thank you